what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
loki episode 3
is only a couple of days away where
we're expecting some pretty big reveals
loki has already given us plenty of
things to talk about including the
multiverse different variants
secret wars kang all very very exciting
subjects that i will be talking a lot
more about but today
i want to talk about how loki actually
sets up
spider-man no way home and how not only
does it give us
more evidence of toby maguire spider-man
showing up along with andrew garfield
spider-man but
it actually explains kind of how they're
going to show up
and of course not only is loki going to
affect no way home but it's also going
to affect multiverse of madness pretty
much the same way it affects spider-man
no way home so
this video really is about both but i'm
gonna try to keep the focus on
spider-man
also my marvel cheer giveaway with and a
seat ends in 10 days so click the link
in the description down below so you can
enter
now if you haven't seen loki episode 2 i
will be talking about spoilers
specifically around the different
variants of loki
and we are starting with the spoilers
now when we get out on the branch we're
not just
looking for a time criminal we're
looking for a loki a variation of
this guy the type we should all be very
familiar with because the tva has pruned
a lot of these guys almost more than any
other variant
and no two are alike slight differences
in appearances or not so slight
different powers although powers
generally include shape-shifting
illusion projection
so in this very clear and very obvious
scene in loki we saw
different variants of loki the first
loki was a loki
as a frost giant which of course he
truly is the next one was a very sporty
loki
and then we got a hulk version of loki
which even confused him himself
his last run-in with the hulk wasn't
exactly pleasant
enough you are all of you beneath me
i am a god you dull creature and i will
not be bullied by that
[Applause]
puny god but the bottom line of the
scene and the main point of this
is to show that all loki's don't exactly
look alike
they look relatively similar but not
necessarily 100
the same now there's actually so many
different variants of loki that mobius
says there are many different ones
almost
more than any other variant and he
specifically says
no two are alike there are slight
differences in appearances
or not so slight differences in
appearances
now this answers a question that some
fans have been asking about spider-man
no way home
about toby and andrew showing up and
that is they don't look alike they're
not going to actually be
the same spider-man they're going to be
different and the answer to that
is actually both yes and no no they
aren't the same because they
are indeed going to be from another
universe but yes they
are they are the same in the fact that
they are peter parker and they are
spider-man mobius even goes on to say
that the powers can also differ
and this explains another key difference
in one of the spider-man that we're
going to see
specifically toby maguire spider-man see
all three of these spider-man have
pretty much the same abilities the
classic spider-man abilities except for
toby maguire spider-man
his spider-man actually produces organic
web
and he shoots them from his arm instead
of a web shooter and these differences
have just been explained what it seems
like they're doing here in the loki
series
is setting up the future to not have
that many questions or
confusion about what is happening in
loki they are establishing the
multiverse which i'm about to get into
and they are establishing that not every
version of the character has to look the
same despite whatever character it is
even loki has
female versions of himself so not only
can the characters slightly differ but
they could be a completely different
gender and they can be
a completely different being as we saw
him as sort of a hulk so loki episode 2
set up different variations of the same
character
that look different so we can have
thousands of different loki who
are still loki but look different and
have different abilities much like we're
going to have three different spider-man
who look different but kind of have the
same abilities all
still spider-man this could also set up
a female peter parker which they could
do we haven't heard
any rumors or news about that i would
probably rather see jessica drew or
spider gwen but hey who knows
with the multiverse anything is possible
and what happened in the last episode of
loki the multiverse went
into madness and loki escaped from the
tva
and followed the female loki so we know
that there's going to be a conversation
between the two of them because we've
seen it in
a trailer we don't know what they're
talking about but we can probably assume
that lady loki is going to
somewhat reveal her plan to arloki now
with her
setting the multiverse into madness it
of course sets up multiverse of madness
but it also sets up spiderman no way
home
now we're not really sure of what's
going to happen with this sacred
timeline in the loki series right now
the tba has been dispatched to try
and fix all of these different time
branches but we know that once the nexus
point crosses the red line
they can't go back they can't undo what
has happened and
a branch timeline has been created
forever i'm sure the tva is going to
manage to erase
some of them before they hit the red
line but since we do have a movie called
multiverse of madness and spiderman no
way home is going to deal with the
multiverse as well i'm sure
not all of those different branches are
going to be deleted in fact i'm not even
sure if the tva is still going to be
left standing by the end of the loki
series
i'm definitely thinking that kang is
somewhat in charge of the tva right now
but we'll see how that plays out
got a big theory about that coming
either tomorrow or the next day
but we know that the supposed focus of
our loki is to take down the timekeepers
to
overthrow them loki doesn't like the
idea of somebody else controlling his
destiny he doesn't like the idea of
fate even though ironically enough he
was the one that wanted to control
everybody
because he said it's easier for them yet
the guy himself has a hard time being
controlled
so i guess it's not really easier but
he's gonna take down the timekeepers
anyways or at least he's going to try
and then
lady loki clearly has a plan to get rid
of the tva
because although she is different and
seems to be quite superior
she is still loki which means she is
also going to struggle with
freedom with fate so by the end of the
loki series they think these two loki's
might actually take down
the tva which means there could be
thousands
millions billions of different timelines
created because there's going to be no
organization or timekeepers or anything
to stop the timelines from being created
or erased them when they
are created and this is how we're going
to get spider-man no way home this is
how we're going to get the different
variants of our peter parker marvel is
kind of putting this
right in front of our eyes here setting
up toby and andrew to appear in no way
home
the multiverse will be in madness and
these are just going to be different
variants of peter parker
and then supposedly we're going to be
seeing a lot of different variants of
a lot of different characters in doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
one rumor that i've heard that i
personally really really
really hope is true is that we're going
to be getting different
versions or variations we'll say now of
captain america
of iron man of black widow a bunch of
different characters played by actors
who
could have played them for example john
krasinski could show up as a variant of
captain america tom cruise could show up
as a variant of iron man
emily blunt a variant of black widow i
think this would be pretty cool to see
since those characters could have played
those roles that was a possibility at
one point in time
and if we kind of want to try and speak
somewhat realistically if the multiverse
was real there is a reality that exists
where they actually got those roles and
that is essentially the reality that we
would be seen
in multiverse of madness and then of
course i am always crossing my fingers
that we could dip into the timeline or
the different
universe or multiverse where the fox
universe lies and we could see
characters like
hugh jackman's wolverine patrick
stewart's professor x
and ian mckellen's magneto after all
patrick stewart himself confirmed that
he met with
kevin feige the president of marvel
studios to talk about
some future endeavors but we do know
that patrick stewart said he's done with
professor x so
we know he's not really returning as
professor x but
in multiverse of madness to do a quick
cameo that's not really him returning
that's not undoing his death from logan
it's just a quick little fun cameo so
i'm crossing my fingers for that
although it's not confirmed at all so
don't act like it is
but this is how loki sets up no way home
in multiverse of madness and they're
doing it right in front of our eyes
they're starting to set it up to where
everything is going to make sense when
we eventually get to no way home we
won't have a lot of questions
it won't be that confusing because
they're going to get rid of all of that
confusion
right now in loki different variants are
established and the multiverse will be
established as well
and spider-man far from home will make
complete sense but go ahead and let me
know what you think about this
in the comments down below don't forget
to like this video and for live updates
you can follow me on
instagram and twitter as always thank
you all so much for watching
woof
you